[Music]
are we anywhere near Old Mill Bernie
yeah
because we got all these buildings well
if I had to guess where all those cars
are that's probably Old Mill Bernie so
we're probably not far off
here
what do y'all want to do guys are
getting a little tired but we gotta at
least keep walking because right now if
he's walking we're on a track
yeah yeah like let's let's push yeah
y'all want to clear those buildings
it's me
good here law
yers
[Music]
[Music]
hey you might be prone behind that
yeah
hey the guys that are out here were
shots fired what y'all got in there
[Music]
hey I'm going to coordinate EMS
locations
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey this is Raleigh standby we need that
address for EMS
[Music]
three three
single two five one five three three
McConnell Oliver Drive
to the hospital
yeah
make sure the backside that's covered
yeah
[Music]
foreign
perimeter on this
today we're handling it now the bonus is
on the way
right now
[Music]
I'm far right I'm right I'm right
those lights are off
all right
knee
[Applause]